teaching a dog means giving treats for
good behavior and correcting for
mistakes in machine learning there is a
similar idea called reinforcement
learning AR lets a computer figure
things out on its own by getting rewards
for good actions and penalties for the
wrong ones there are different types of
reinforcement learnings first is the
positive reinforcement it is like giving
treat for a good dog behavior the model
gets reward for the right decision
whereas a negative reinforcement similar
to correcting a dog the model faces
penalties for wrong action encouraging
it to avoid those choices if we talk
about exploration versus exploitation
this is like dog trying new tricks in
form of exploration but also sticking to
what works with that being said guys if
you want to learn more about machine
learning check out the link in the
description box but do you know